[Music]
my name is Knapp loom burg I'm a product
manager on the chrome team and today I'm
going to talk about Chrome browser in
the enterprise I'll leave some time at
the end for Q&A and also note that we
have a space the Android and chrome
sandbox in Moscone on the third floor so
please feel just drop stopped by there
tomorrow at a time so it's just a quick
overview of the agenda again really just
going to cover a lot of the features for
Chrome in the enterprise and again happy
to take questions at the end so first
we're going to kind of cover why would
your company want to switch to chrome
what are some of the benefits of using
chrome in your enterprise by a show of
hands who's using chrome today at the
office okay so mission accomplished so
starting off with our key pillars every
feature that we design has these key
pillars in mind so when we start with
speed we know speed is very important
and it's every second counts when you're
trying to complete a task and we want
chrome to be as responsive and
conservative with system resources as
possible from a simplicity perspective
we want to delight our users and
optimize for predictability with concise
actions and solutions and we know
security is one of the most critical
areas for enterprises and we want to be
as transparent regarding security and
privacy by ensuring users are informed
in non-technical terms I'm sure you've
seen off snap or green padlocks red
lines listed certificates aren't valid
in the omnibox and we safeguard our
users by allowing them by letting them
know that they're protected as well as
warn them before reaching the licious
sites and from a managed ill
manageability perspective we want to
give IT administrators every bit of
control over their end users experience
as possible so in the old days you'd
have a native app for opening PDFs and
another one for spreadsheets another one
for for documents and so on but we
really see the web browser as a window
into all of your enterprise applications
in the future software upgrades can be
deployed with a simple refresh of the
web page Chrome offers a better
experience for users complete
manageability
RIT and the latest web technology for
developers to build on top of so I'm
sure many of you check your phone in the
morning maybe what on your laptop and
got some things done before coming to
the conference maybe throughout a normal
day in between meetings you go to your
desk and have a desktop PC there in the
evening maybe you check some emails on a
work on a computer at home or on a
tablet the browser becomes the universal
platform across all of these devices and
what they have in common is that they're
all connected the platforms may differ
but why shouldn't your experience be
seamless across every device you use by
signing into Chrome services like Chrome
sync will allow users to easily and
quickly pick up right where they left
off so today every application must run
on every device your users expect that
and they expect it to be seamless across
corporate issue and oftentimes personal
devices the fact is the today's
information workers on average use 10
web apps across three devices to do his
or her job
today's best business applications like
Salesforce and G suite workday and many
others are all web-based even
traditional web additional enterprise
vendors like SAT are now building their
web their new applications for the web
based on html5 and they work very well
in Chrome to empower your employees with
today's best business tools companies
have to use the browser that is the best
support with latest web standards like
html5
we're also seeing a big uptake in
enterprise development of progressive
web apps you may have heard more about
this in other sessions at the conference
but all the features that you have with
native apps such as push notifications
offline functionality adding icons to
home screens on mobile devices launching
in full-screen mode access to the
clipboard all of these things are
possible
in progressive web apps and they can run
across any device mobile or desktop so
when we launched Chrome in September of
2008 the world said who needs another
web browser and if we jump forward to
today we have more than 2 billion users
across chrome desktop and mobile
we are very close I believe today or
tomorrow launching Chrome 57 and we will
and we are seeing html5 and progressive
web app adoption continue to gain
traction in the enterprise specifically
in the past couple years chrome has seen
hyper growth in the enterprise space
we're making large investments on our
Enterprise engineering resources as well
as working closely with our largest
enterprise partners who are building SAS
solutions and aligning on priorities to
ensure those solutions work very well
and we're building the right features
for the future for enterprise customers
the overview here of security and
privacy so we obviously take security
very seriously and secure technologies
like Safe Browsing sandboxing and our
ability to quickly deploy updates or
what makes chrome the most secure
browser available occupant which is now
known as Optive wrote an extensive
report comparing Chrome browser security
to other browsers in the industry
several years ago and it goes into very
much a lot of depth on what the
differentiators are from the chrome
security perspective so feel free to
review that that report we also have
updated content on our website regarding
Chrome security features and we will be
refreshing the security report in the
coming months so you can watch out for
that as well so as I mentioned security
is one of our key pillars and chrome was
designed with security built in and it's
always top of mind during all of our
feature development processes so just to
highlight a few of these features chrome
now offers the ability to generate safe
and easy to use passwords so these are
passwords that you don't have to
remember and you don't really need to
know but they're accessible at any time
chrome visually reassures users that
we're protecting them at the omnibox at
the top of the screen and as I'll talk
about in a minute more on safe browsing
will warn users when they visit
malicious sites we do research to make
sure these warnings are easy to
understand and not scary and complicated
to end-users if chrome detects that a
user's settings have been tampered with
by malware will reset those settings
automatically no tickets to helpdesk no
no other trouble tickets needed so you
always have full control over the
browser experience
we also offer new features such as the
ephemeral profiles which allows users to
of the full chromic signed inexperienced
extensions customizations all of those
things can be used as a normal user but
that profile can automatically be wiped
when they close out Chrome so we're
seeing a lot of interest in this in new
environments such as retail hotels where
there's shared PCs or that's a common
scenario you can also set a passphrase
for syncing your data with chrome to
offer your end-to-end encryption of that
data chrome also leads Chrome's PDF
Reader also leads industry in the
protection of untrustworthy PDFs so it's
very very secure way to do PDFs so
earlier I mentioned how chrome updates
are a critical piece of our story and
the browser has to be updated to be
secure so here's what we're show so in
this example here we're showing the
comparison of speed updates from Safari
and chrome so as you can see here this
data is from cookie comm which is a web
analytics company the shape of the graph
can show over a period of months for old
versions to get updated and died off and
you can see Safari 8 from 2014 actually
is still kicking along so this is very
consistent with browsers with annual
release cycles and other browsers that
don't have automatic update features and
when you compare this to Chrome you can
see the beauty of auto update old
versions disappear very quickly and so
does access to those known
vulnerabilities we have major releases
every six weeks and security updates can
be deployed as needed whenever there's a
security vulnerability discovered by
allowing chrome to auto update you won't
need to wait until Tuesday for security
updates to be deployed Google can deploy
those updates at Google scale so we can
reach hundreds of millions of users
around the world in a matter of hours so
another security feature I want to
highlight is safe browsing safe browsing
will show users a warning message before
they visit a dangerous site or download
a harmful app our scanning
infrastructure also protects the Chrome
Web Store from potentially harmful
extensions this is the same technology
that we use in the Play Store
our technology protects your company
from a range of malware phishing and
Sylla
social engineering attacks that might
try to steal passwords or infect
machines
if an employee encounters a website
suspected of being deceptive or
dangerous while browsing the web they'll
be shown a warning message will also
show warning messages on dangerous
downloads like malware they could inject
ads or again jeopardize your corporate
network how many of you have seen this
this morning message at home okay just a
few so okay good so you're not visiting
sites with malware so discovering these
vulnerabilities are very important to
Google and we've implemented technology
such as fuzzing and cluster fuzz which
run thousands of virtual instances of
chrome running hundreds of millions of
automated tests every day we use this
data to analyze crashes and identify
regressions quickly long before any of
these changes reach the stable channel
of chrome and we know we can't do this
alone
so we created the chrome reward program
in January of 2010 to help reward
security researchers and individuals who
invest their time and energy into
helping us make chrome more safe so we
paid out more than nine million dollars
since this program existed and more than
a third of that was paid out last year
so more folks have been getting involved
in the near term so this I'm going to
just mention a new feature that we're
working on related to security plan for
later this year so we're going to be
adding even more controls for enterprise
admin things such as location determined
security level of the client as well as
user restrictions allow you to both
expand access to your corporate web
applications and at the same time offer
to you the controls you need to ensure
the experience is secure and end so for
example chrome support of security keys
from an administrative perspective can
specify that their employees and users
have to be strongly authenticated to
access a web application from a device
management perspective you'll be able to
monitor client-side state and
configuration on across all major
platforms so this enables the state of
the device to be monitored by the
infrastructure so that the state can be
considered when making an access
decision
the management capability will integrate
with existing device management systems
you already have running and including
system checks such as if the client has
current antivirus software or if the
disk is encrypted things along those
lines will be reported and a decision
will be made as to allowing access these
are some of the examples of the concerns
from our customers talk a little bit
about speed and power improvements so
chrome was built to be fast in every way
we monitor every aspect of speed
regarding startup time page load time
video rendering of graphics complex
complex scripts Java scripts and
business web applications and we also
work very closely with our partners to
maintain top performance with each of
their software releases and of course as
you can see with the octane scores this
is a benchmark of JavaScript speed
there's been significant improvements in
over the last couple years so chrome is
stable because we was built using multi
processing architecture which allocates
each task and every tab running as a
separate process so while we constantly
update chrome with new improvements we
click we can quickly solve any problems
that might cause the browser to crash so
I'm sure if you've been using Chrome for
a long period of time you may have seen
a tab crash but the entire instance
won't so again from a security
perspective process processes are
isolated and they cannot talk across
tabs with each other so regarding power
over the past several releases we've
made large improvements to power
consumption on Chrome and we now have a
large team dedicated to power reduction
so this is just a small example of a
change we made on mobile devices where
we can now refresh only a small part of
a tile as opposed to the whole screen so
this may seem like a very minor change
but this is the type of ongoing effort
to reduce power and energy consumption
for battery-powered devices so I
mentioned the tile redraw but there are
also countless other efforts across
dozens of components to reduce power
consumption across the board so this is
showing the progress we're making
towards reducing power usage in Chrome
and with each release there's been
significant improvements as you
see here so I'll give a quick update on
media as well where we've also made
large improvements on bandwidth usage so
we know that companies use media in many
ways everything ranging from video
conferencing to now news and media and
social media which are now increasingly
video based everything even internal
communications such as training videos
company updates are now shifting to be
streaming video to enable access for
employees across multiple locations
chrome has extensive support for WebRTC
which is used for video conferencing and
we are working and we are now working
hard to improve video codecs to decrease
bandwidth usage while maintaining the
same video quality while I'm not allowed
to share the exact YouTube stats to give
you a sense of the scale of video watch
time in chrome it's truly staggering
there are thousands of years of video
played in Chrome every day so what else
can we do to improve this area chrome
supports the latest video codecs
including vp9 to improve quality and
reduce bandwidth so you can see here the
image on the left is clearer and uses
30% less bandwidth than h.264 which is
on the right
chrome also supports DRM which allows
you to protect your sensitive corporate
videos this support is deployed through
a component called Widevine which is
available across Mac Windows Linux
Android and Chrome OS we also support we
now allow users to download secure
content and offline video playback is
supported as well when you playback
videos chrome can also cast that to
larger screens or other devices for
easier viewing so as I mentioned vp9
will save more than 30% of video
bandwidth to the same quality this can
result in so 30% savings on a video
encoded at one megabit bitrate for a
thousand employees would equate to more
than a gig of mobile data savings per
day and obviously one one megabit video
bitrate is very low so can obviously add
up in addition to video Chrome has
support for WebP II which is a higher
image quality than JPEG at the same file
size
so for companies with large internal
image databases this also can improve
visual quality and save on storage so we
talked a little bit about some of the
chrome Enterprise Management features so
today there are a couple hundred
management features that allow you to
control the chrome experience end-to-end
everything from setting a home page to
force deploying extensions to
configuring a proxy servers all of these
things can be deployed within your
existing Active Directory infrastructure
or through our cloud-based console it's
the same it's the same Chrome browser
that uses they're familiar with but now
IT can customize it to meet your
company's needs we are also now offering
a 24/7 enterprise support offering
should you need to troubleshoot or
escalate any issues without with our
team now we we know very well that
moving to the open web is not going to
happen overnight and those legacy
applications from 10 and 15 years ago
that used Silverlight and ActiveX are
not going anywhere in the near future we
know that you rely on those apps every
day and we want to make it as easy and
seamless as possible for you debt for
your users to access those applications
so we built a tool called legacy browser
support and this will allow admins to
configure Chrome as the default browser
and define a number of sites that should
still be opened with an alternative
browser when when the user is done with
the legacy browser and legacy property
it will be single be seamless seamlessly
switched back to Chrome to resume where
they left off no training or change
management needed so while Chrome's auto
update feature enables your company to
be on this basis fastest version of
Chrome we know that many companies also
want flexibility when making these types
of changes and upgrades so you can
choose to leave auto-update on to get
those security fixes or you can also
disable auto updates and manage the
timing of updates on your own schedule
based on your organization's needs for
example you may only want to allow
updates at certain times or weekends or
you want to deploy after you've had more
time to test a new release and those are
all fully supported through group policy
that can be configured across all
platforms
so Chrome connects to Google for tools
that require access to our cloud for
example predictive search or translate
features we'll need to connect to Google
you can always happen you will always
have control to turn off these features
and control what data is shared with
Google again all configurable by policy
so as you run more and more of your
business on the web you can use policies
to define what absent extensions get
published to your employees in an
upcoming release of Chrome we're going
to be offering admins even more control
over applications and extensions by
allowing them to restrict which
extensions can be deployed based on the
permission the app or extension declares
for example today it's very common for
administrators to control applications
through a whitelist or blacklist with
this new feature instead of having to
kind of curate what applications are
allowed or blacklist applications that
you discover after the fact you'll be
able to restrict every extension for
example that needs to access the webcam
or the microphone and then not have to
get into reviewing each extension
manually this also will include future
updates for extensions so if you have a
note-taking extension deploy today and
in the future it for some reason needs a
microphone that would automatically be
disabled as you want to monitor every
single update of Chrome extensions so
Chrome is the only browser that is
cross-platform and can be managed from a
single cloud-based console and we
believe the browser should be stateless
and that management should be easy no
matter what device the user picks up so
we offer Chrome enterprise support from
due to customer demand so we understand
that it's a blocker for many companies
to move to Chrome if they're unable to
get enterprise level support directly
from from Google so we begin offering
this last year and it's worth noting
that this is targeted specifically for
non G Suite customers if you already are
a GC customer this is this services
included and this is more targeted for
larger enterprises typically more than a
thousand users or more so that concludes
my remarks thank you
[Music]
you